and as you're getting ready to head out
the door this morning just remember
masks are back in clark county
if you work inside in a public place you
have to cover your face again
the goal from county officials to try
and slow the spread of the new delta
variant of the coronavirus
hector mejia live this morning with some
reaction to this hectic good morning to
you
hey there john good morning certainly a
lot of mixed feelings over the face mask
and having to wear it but right now
it's only a recommend it's only a
requirement for employees and a
recommendation for customers so some are
questioning
just how effective this new requirement
will be
and tuesday was when the clark county
commission voted to require masks for
all employees
working indoors whenever they're walking
around public spaces
that's in effect at least until august
the 17th
the county is working with the health
district right now to figure out
benchmarks
and then what to do next health
officials say the delta variant is
behind a steady rise in the cases among
unvaccinated people here
since there's no way to verify who is
vaccinated
officials brought back the mandate but
again it's only for employees
one woman who works on the las vegas
strip robin mcdermott told us
she doesn't think it'll be very
effective and here's why
they're telling us now we gotta wear
masks as employees
whether you're vaccinated or not and
that's okay
but they're telling us that customers
don't have to wear masks
and like who are we protecting
officials say vaccines are the best way
to handle the problem right now they add
that those vaccines are free
safe effective and available to everyone
but still
there's been a lot of hesitancy around
the vaccine